Ever since I was a kid
so the Sea's been calling I'm
setting out to follow my dreams
I'm gonna be king of the Pirates
together we make a pretty good team
all I need is a loyal crew and I think
we're heading up to the Grand line
the treacherous stretch of Ocean bigger Pirates
bigger islands
that I don't work for you I'm sensing a
little bit of tension amongst the crew
we haven't sailed together for very long
but I know we've got each other's back
all the great Fighters call out
their finishing moves no they don't
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this will
be my Netflix one piece trailer video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references to
the original manga here they're basically doing
the story of the manga through the first couple
of arcs but they're condensing it down to about
Eight Episodes so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I will do videos
for the Netflix episodes when it starts August
31st but as you probably guessed there is no way
no way Netflix is ever going to be able to adapt
the entire story of The One Piece manga Oda just
announced that he's planning on ending it around
2024 2025. we'll see about that but right now
there's well over a thousand chapters of the
manga and even though it looks like they're doing
up through chapter 41 44 maybe 45 something like
that like the first 18 to 20 episodes of the
anime I'm expecting them to get to at least
four or five seasons which is about standard
like stranger things is getting Five Seasons I
just did a trailer video for their avatar The Last
Airbender live action series that'll probably go
maybe like four or five seasons for example what
they'll probably do is just try to get through
the entire Eastern blue Saga of the manga which
is like the first 61 episodes of the anime they
could probably condense that down if they're going
to be doing almost 20 episodes for season one here
but just starting at the beginning of the trailer
as you can probably tell they've mixed around some
of the events and the way characters debut in the
manga so they all meet each other way way sooner
the first scene is of Luffy seeing red Shanks
ship the red Forest when he meets their group
for the first time in fuchsia Village the barati
is the restaurant ship run by itself it's where
Sanji works it doesn't show up in the manga till
like after the Thriller bark Arc way later which
is chapter 43 so this explains how they introduce
Sanji way sooner in the story because a lot of the
mains are in most of the episodes which if they
were doing things exactly like the manga some of
them wouldn't show up to like the very end of the
season so I think part of the idea in rearranging
some of these meetings to make them happen sooner
is that they can bring the straw hats together way
sooner there are a couple direct shots that mirror
shots from the manga starting at the beginning of
the trailer too when he declares he's going to
be become king of the Pirates that's right out
of the manga he tells red Shanks his mentor
like he declares this scene is of orange town
and Buggy's Castle because he's become one of the
four Emperors of the world and that's what Luffy
is talking about becoming this is buggy later in
the trailer this is his ship the big top when he
and red Shanks were younger they both used to
be apprentices as part of the Roger Pirates but
they both since become one of the four Emperors
buggies basically like the first huge villain in
the story this scene is of Zorro when Luffy finds
him all tied up and offers to make him part of
his crew that's why in the trailer he's saying
all he needs to do is find a loyal crew Soro is
a weapons Master primarily a swordsman like he
uses the three swords there but these events are
happening in shellstown later in the story The
Picture behind him is of axhan Morgan who rules
there when this is happening and he becomes one of
the next big villains after buggy when he mentions
they're heading out on the grand line the ship in
the scene isn't the Mary yet he had a few boats
before they got the Mary the first one he gets
when he leaves home for the first time the second
boat he stole from alvida this is the boat he uses
to go to Orange town where Zoro was then he gets
a slightly bigger ship that Nami stole from buggy
none of these early ships were named they didn't
get a name ship until they got the Mary later in
the story which they featured a lot of the behind
the scenes footage so I do think they're going to
get the merry at the end of season one then they
introduce Nami who they meet during the orange
Town Arc she's stolen a map of the grand line from
buggy and was on the run from his group of pirates
when Luffy literally falls out of the sky he helps
her she reluctantly joins him also because he
needs her map that she stole of the grand line
the outfit she's wearing here when she's talking
is the one she was wearing in the mug at that time
so they're trying to be as accurate as possible
to the costumes in the manga this is his encounter
with the lord of the coast earlier in the story
he's one of the smallest sea Kings they're
typically much bigger more dangerous sea creatures
the bigger Pirates quote that Nami is referencing
is too buggy this is his ship that they're
fighting when he starts joking about there being
tension amongst their group this is the treasure
chest that Nami stole for a buggy when they first
meet when she escaped his group with the map she
literally hid an empty Treasure Chest the metal
ship with the Mast of a dog holding a bone is for
the Marines they're like the world government sea
Force that's what the flag on the ship is for
the mark of the world government so in the world
of One Piece they have three great Powers the
four pirate Emperors the world government and
the Seven Warlords the world government is sort
of like this corrupt organization that tries to
execute their own absolute Justice anybody that
they don't like basically during the entire story
of One Piece like one of the big running gags is
they put out bounties on Luffy all the different
Pirates heads and during each Arc of the manga
the bounty on him keeps going up as he does
crazier and crazier things they do this for all
the main characters pretty much all the Pirate
characters in general and as their importance
their prominence in the story in the world grows
so do their bounties so the bounties themselves
are kind of like a low-level ranking system with
the best most powerful Pirates having the highest
bounties on them so the higher your Bounty is the
more important to The Story You're supposed to be
then they introduce yusub he's the next member of
the crew in the manga they encounter him at syrup
Island when they're looking for a new ship and he
tries to trick them into thinking that he's this
powerful pirate Commander but it's meant to be a
big funny moment that he fails at utterly and
eventually they befriend him when they realize
that he's the son of one of the pirates that
was part of red shank's crew Luffy's Mentor
when they keep talking about sailing to bigger
more dangerous Islands I think that's Nami that's
saying that that's basically the main idea of One
Piece like that's how the story works is they just
basically sail to a new island and have a new
adventure through each part of the story this
is Sanji he's wearing a suit like he was when
they first met in the manga they just moved his
meeting way up in the story this is back when
Luffy's trying to free Zoro earlier in Orange
Town Zorro's move with the three swords and one in
his mouth is right out of the manga Nami helping
them they all meet in Orange town but they might
change some of the events of this big Escape scene
then at the end of the trailer he finally uses
his gum gum devil fruit Powers as he calls it
out stretching his hand giving you an idea for
what some of the special effects will look like
obviously it'll be a little bit crazier than this
it's just like a teaser at the special effects and
the main title was just designed to look like
a 3D version of oda's title from the original
manga but basically it seems like they're starting
with the romance Dawn Saga and being relatively
accurate just moving some things up and doing
all the way through the Thriller bark Saga or
at least the beginning of the Thriller bark Saga
because that's when Sanji shows up they wind up
getting them married during the syrup Village
Arc I'm assuming they're pushing that to like
the last two episodes if not the last episode
though what they'll probably do is just start
with a speed run version of Luffy's origin
story really quickly in part of episode what
like really quickly age him up as he meets the
red hair Pirates and then decides to become the
new pirate king and find the hidden treasure the
legendary treasure hidden by the former pirate
king gold D Roger which is one of the biggest
tropes of the series like the whole idea is that
he's still looking like thousands of chapters
later he's still looking for that treasure you
can let me know in the comments even if you're
not a manga reader if you ever think that he's
going to find that Treasure by the time the One
Piece manga ends if Oda will let him find the
treasure or it will be one of those situations
where it's like the treasure was the friends we
made all along the way I am expecting there to
be some sort of actual Treasure by the end of
that would be weird though if there was no actual
treasure at all basically his origin is the straw
hats themselves are named after Luffy's straw hat
which was given to him by his mentor red Shanks
leader of the red Shanks Pirates one of the four
pirate Emperors of the world Luffy doesn't give
his crew that name though it's another pirate
early during their adventures and the name just
stuck like I said there are a couple different
villains during that first Arc that they'll do
during season one like you have buggy then you
have ax hand and if you're trying to follow along
in the anime to see what they changed episode
to episode like I think they're doing about the
first 18 to 20 episodes of the anime I know a
lot of people are put off by the whole concept
of them doing live-action anime because Cowboy
Bebop was not a good series I was not a fan of
what they did changing Cowboy Bebop a bunch from
the original anime a lot of people also waiting
to see some actual footage from Avatar The Last
Airbender live-action Netflix series the costumes
look pretty accurate so it does look promising
and what they've done recently is they've delayed
avatar the Last airbender's Premiere till
early 2020 24 maybe like spring 2024 just so
they have time to polish the special effects
which I think will help a lot Oda said that
he was heavily involved with the making of their
live-action one piece Series so it does feel like
even though they're changing some stuff they'll
try to be as accurate as possible but obviously
it won't be exactly like the manga or the anime
there's a bunch more Easter eggs during this that
I probably didn't talk about so if you didn't
spot any big Easter eggs or references to the
manga or the anime just write them Below in the
comments and just post your reactions in general
there were a bunch more trailers that Netflix
dropped at their recent events so I'll try to
do videos for all that as quickly as possible I
just did a video for the live action avatar The
Last Airbender trailer and the first looks at all
their characters click here to learn about that
and click here for my flash movie alternate ending
alternate post credit scenes and deleted scenes
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!